I'm very pleased to be here and thank
you for that introduction tonight this
evening I'd like to call your attention
to attention and let me begin with a
story it's about a classic experiment in
social psychology it was done many years
ago at the Princeton Theological
Seminary with divinity students each
student was told that they're going to
give a practice sermon they'd receive a
topic to prepare and then they go to
another building and give the sermon to
be evaluated half of the students were
given the parable of the Good Samaritan
as their topic the man who stopped to
help the stranger in need by the side of
the road the other half were given
random Bible topics as each divinity
student went over to the other building
to give their sermon they passed a man
who was bent over and moaning in pain
the interesting question is did they
stop to help the more interesting
question is did it matter if they're
pondering the parable of the Good
Samaritan what do you think
didn't matter make no difference at all
what mattered was how much time pressure
people felt they're under and this is
more or less the story of our lives
there's a spectrum that runs from
noticing the other person to tuning into
the other person to empathizing and
understanding what's going on with them
and then if they're in need and there's
something we can do
compassion and maybe helping them but if
we never notice in the first place we
never go down that road and this is the
problem with attention today it's under
siege
I think the moment I knew we're in
trouble was a while back before I
started writing the book focus I was on
my way to a meeting I was driving I live
out in the country in New England I was
late but I was wanting people there to
know I was coming so as
I was driving I was texting them on my
way
that's rather horrible because it turns
out as I read not very long after that
that texting while driving is the same
as drinking while driving it's really
bad in fact in my state it's outlawed
now another thing I've noticed is when I
was writing the book I'd be kind of on a
riff really in flow writing well then
I'd have to look something up so I go to
Google Scholar I love Google Scholar
because it gives you access to the
academic database so I opened my web
browser and my web browser presents me
with the news of the day and I'm a news
junkie so all of a sudden I start
reading news stories and before I know
it I've been lot you know fifteen twenty
minutes has gone by before I realized
that oh I was supposed to be looking
that up and today we're all in the same
boat and that the tools that we use our
computer our phone and so on are also
devised to interrupt us to seduce us to
draw our attention from this to that and
usually under that is trying to sell us
something a pop-up ad or whatever but
attention is besieged in a way that has
never been true before when I was going
around to publishers and telling him I
wanted to write about attention one
publishers said to me that's wonderful
we'd love to have that book but could
you keep it short
so what happened to us in in 2007 Time
magazine a major American publication
had a small article it said there's a
new word in the English language the
word is pizzle it's a combination of
puzzled and pissed-off and it refers to
the moment when you're with someone who
takes out their blackberry and starts
talking to someone else and ignoring you
in 2007 that was unusual but the word
pizzle has died with the blackberry
because now that's the new social norm
you go out to a dinner very romantic
restaurant you see a couple together and
they're both looking at their phones
instead of into each other's eyes
something has happened to us in 1977
Nobel Prize winner Herbert Simon wrote a
very prescient he said information
consumes attention hence a wealth of
information creates a poverty of
attention I think we've entered a time
when we're in danger of intentional
impoverishment and the the signs of it
are more than you know a couple watching
they're looking at the phone instead of
it into each other's eyes you the other
day I saw a mom holding a little toddler
and the toddler's trying to get her
attention and she's busy texting he's
just not available and you know of
course dad's same story I was on a
vacation island last summer Martha's
Vineyard off the coast of New England
and I was taking a taxi from the ferry
to my house and I happened to share it
with seven sorority sisters college
students who were going for a weekend
together and we got in the it was a
shared taxi a big van and we got in the
taxi and within a minute or two every
one of the sorority sisters was staring
into a screened iphone/ipad but they
weren't talking to each other and I
think this is a real long
the ingredients of rapport are three the
first is full mutual attention from that
full attention comes a second ingredient
it's a nonverbal synchrony if you look
at two people who are really in rapport
really connecting if you were to make a
video of that and watch it in silence
the two bodies look as though they're
choreographed this is something that's
managed by a category of brain cell
called oscillators oscillators govern
how we respond to someone else how we
respond to physical objects oscillators
are very important for the survival of
the human species consider this at the
moment of a first kiss they determine
the velocity at which two skulls come
together and if they get it wrong it
would be the end of the species I'm sure
the third ingredient after the full
attention and the nonverbal synchrony is
that it feels good it's a rather
pleasant joyous state to connect with
someone that well these are the moments
in our lives that are the richest that
that really matter however recently
there was an article in the Harvard
Business Review called the human moment
it said if you want to have real
connection with someone and if they come
into your office or remember this turn
away from your screen ignore your phone
and on every other device stop your
daydream or whatever's on your mind
and pay full attention to the person in
front of you I find it said that we have
to have an article in a Harvard Business
Review to tell us something like that
but it has come to this because
attention is a rarer and rarer commodity
but it's a very precious commodity I
think the time has come for us to take
an active stand in our lives
and fight back against this subtle
onslaught I know a couple for example
who when they come home have a pact that
they'll put their phones in a drawer
they won't look at them for the evening
there's a new way of getting together I
don't know if this has happened here in
the UK but in the States for example
when people get together for dinner
everybody takes their phone out puts it
in the middle of the table and the first
person that reaches for their phone
before the bill comes has to pay the
bill now there's not just one kind of
tension attention there's several
varieties the most obvious is selective
attention when we focus on one thing and
ignore others there are two main kinds
of distractors two general classes one
is sensory distractors so if you're
looking at me you're probably not
noticing this whiteboard here right
that's relatively easy the tough one is
the second category it's emotional
distractors our emotional distractors
are extremely powerful they're thoughts
about that conversation that didn't go
so well the Tiff's I had with my partner
this morning the mostly relationship
concerns things that have upset us so
the more focused we are the better we do
at anything as a rather obvious but for
example a test of concentration among
athletes predicts how well they'll do
the next season that's rather
straightforward and the less our mind
wanders or students mind modern rule
reading a text the better we comprehend
the text however it turns out on average
while we're reading a book our mind
wanders about twenty to forty percent of
the time I think it depends on the book
that particular study was done with
Pride and Prejudice
if it had been done say with I don't
know fifty shades of gray or blink or
whatever it might have been different
but the the point is that the more
disrupted attention is particularly for
young people the harder it is for them
to grasp to build the cumulative mental
models that amount to mastery and in any
subject there are basically three modes
of attention I want to call your
attention to and here's a schematic so
this is generally the relationship
between performance say this is high
this is low and this is the the
horizontal line is brain activity
particularly levels of stress hormones
like cortisol adrenaline and the
relationship is very telling it goes
like this
it's an upside-down U and the highest
performance is when attention is
absolutely a hundred percent maybe a
hundred and ten percent
it's been called flow flow is discovered
for those of you who don't know about it
by researchers who asked people in in
many different domains of expertise
basketball players ballerinas
neurosurgeons tell us about a time you
outdid yourself
you were absolutely at your best even
you were surprised and no matter what
the domain was people were describing
the same phenomena djegal state and one
of the characteristics of the state is
that attention is utterly absorbed there
was a neurosurgeon who said I had to do
a surgery an operation that I didn't
really know if I could it was so
difficult but I did it superbly I was
really surprised myself at the end of
the surgery I looked around and I saw
some rubble in the corner of the
operating theatre I said what happened
they said while you were operating the
roof
you didn't over there and you didn't
notice it's that kind of attention it's
unbreakable it's also a state where your
skills are called upon at the utmost and
whatever the demand is you can meet it
you're very flexible very adaptable and
very tellingly it's a state that feels
good it's it's like rapport rapport is
mutual flow interpersonal flow so that's
when focus is a hundred percent when you
have too much to do too little time
too little support when you feel
overwhelmed you're down here and the
stress hormones at their highest you're
in a state which was called recently in
the scientific journal action of the
journal Science in an article was called
the neurobiology of frazzle I don't know
if you're familiar with frazzle I've
been there many times it's constant
stress and here the problem is you can't
stop thinking about what's upsetting you
what's stressing you you're not focusing
here you're not focusing on the task at
hand
you're focusing on what's upsetting you
and that's the power of emotions
emotions take over attention they guide
attention and if they're too strong then
you'll never get up here over here
performance is low because people are
under motivated disengage this is a huge
problem of disengagement in the
workplace people feel in fact there was
a survey this is really interesting was
done at Harvard 2,500 people are given
an iPhone app and the app rings them at
random times during the day and they
answer two questions what are you doing
now and what are you thinking about now
and the discrepancy of course is a lot
as a measure of mind wandering turns out
50 percent of the time on average our
minds are wandering the one activity
that had the highest focus no surprise
was making love but who fills out that
at a time like that I still haven't been
able to figure that out the the lowest
three were commuting sitting at a
computer and work that's this so if
you're not engaged in what you're doing
your cortisol levels are too low so I've
been talking about focusing as though it
were the only valuable kind of attention
but actually mind wandering which is the
enemy of focusing the term they use in
brain sciences they are anti-correlated
if your mind is wandering by definition
you're not focusing and vice versa mind
wandering is absolutely essential for
creative insight the creative process
demands that first of all you gather
information you focus on the problem you
really concentrate and then you let go
the annals of science art and
mathematics are full of people who came
up with incredible solutions when
they're just daydreaming in the shower
getting on a bus walking your dog and
that's because during mind-wandering
we're able to make connections between
remote elements in a new way that has
value that's the definition of a
creative act of course if you're going
to execute if you're going to put the
idea to use then you have to go back
into focus but mind-wandering is
extremely extremely valuable there's
another level that which attention
operates this has to do with leadership
but I argue that leaders need three
kinds of focus to be really effective
the first is an inner focus let me tell
you about a case that's actually from
the annals of Neurology there was a
corporate lawyer who unfortunately had a
small prefrontal brain tumor it was
discovered early operated
successfully after the surgery though he
it was very puzzling picture because he
was absolutely as smart as he had been
before a very high IQ no problem with
the tension or memory but he couldn't do
his job anymore he couldn't do any job
he in fact he ended up out of work his
wife left him he lost his home he's
living in his brother's spare bedroom
and in despair he went to see a famous
neurologist named Antonio Damasio
Damacio specializes in the circuitry
between the prefrontal area which is
where we consciously pay attention to
what matters now where we make decisions
where we learn and the emotional centers
in the midbrain particularly the
amygdala which is our radar for radar
for danger it triggers our strong
emotions they had cut the connection
between the prefrontal area and
emotional centers and demacia at first
was puzzled he he realized that this
fellow on every neurological test was
perfectly fine but he something was
wrong and then he got a clue he asked
the lawyer when should we have our next
appointment and he realized the lawyer
could give him the rationale pros and
cons of every hour for the next two
weeks but he didn't know which is best
and Damacio says when we're making a
decision any decision when to have the
next appointment should I leave my job
for another one what strategy should we
follow going into the future who should
I marry this fellow compared to all the
other fellows I mean those are decisions
that require we draw on our entire life
experience and the circuitry that
collects that life experience is very
base brain it's very ancient in the
brain and it has no direct connection to
the part of the brain that thinks in
words it has very rich connectivity to
the Castro intestinal tract to the gut
so we get a gut feeling feels right
doesn't feel right Damacio calls them
somatic markers it's a language of the
body and the ability to tune into this
is extremely important because this is
valuable data - they did a study of
California entrepreneurs and asked them
how do you make your decisions these are
people
who built a business from nothing to
hundreds of millions or billions of
dollars and they more or less said the
same strategy I'm a voracious gatherer
of information I want to see the numbers
but if it doesn't feel right I won't go
ahead with the deal they're tuning into
the gut feelings I know someone I grew
up in a farm region of California the
Central Valley and my high school had a
rival High School in the next town and I
met him someone who went to that other
high school he almost he was not a good
student he almost failed it didn't
graduate came close to not graduating
high school he went to a two-year
college at community college that we
call them found his way into film which
he loved and got into a film school in
film school his student project caught
the eye of a director who asked him to
become an assistant and he did so well
at that that the director arranged for
him to direct his own film someone
else's script he did so well at that
they let him direct a script that he had
written and that film did surprisingly
well so the studio that financed that
film said if you want to do another one
we will back you and he however hated
the way the studio edited the film he
felt he was a creative artist and they
had butchered his art he said I'm gonna
do the film on my own I'm gonna finance
it myself
this was everyone in the film business
that he knew said this is a huge mistake
you shouldn't do this but he went ahead
then he ran out of money
had to go to 11 banks before he could
get a loan he finished managed to finish
the film you may have seen the film it's
called Star Wars so George Lucas made a
decision on the basis of his gut it
didn't feel right to let the studio
mangle his next gnome he read was his
integrity and this inner sense is
ethical it's an ethical writer you know
it answers the question is what I'm
about to do in keeping with my sense of
meaning values
and ethics that's not a question that we
answer first in words we answer first
and what feels right and doesn't feel
right then we put it into words and
every leader today needs a strong
ethical rudder so I'd say an inner
awareness inner focus is essential then
there's other focus which is being able
to read people being able to tune into
the person there are three kinds of
empathy and this is empathy I'm talking
about the first is cognitive cognitive
empathy means I understand how you think
about things
your mental models how you see the world
what that means is I'm able to
communicate with you in terms you really
understand you really resonate with
managers leaders who are able to talk to
other people with good cognitive empathy
are able to get better than expected
performance out of people because they
know how to mobilize them they know what
matters then there's emotional empathy
emotional empathy is an immediate felt
sense of what's going on in the other
person and this is absolutely essential
to if you only have cognitive empathy
and you don't have emotional empathy
you'll be you'll miss the mark the Third
Kind of empathy is very important too
it's empathic concern not only do I know
how you think and how you feel but if
there's something I something you need
and I can help you with I'm predisposed
to help the leaders who have the most
loyalty who people love working for have
all three kinds of empathy there's an
article in the Harvard Business Review
called leadership run amok leadership
run amok is about people who may have
cognitive empathy but lack the other two
these are leaders who are very good at
hitting the target for example but don't
care about what happens to the people
that they manage they have no feeling
for them and so they demoralize people
our people are ready to leave if
Abell the third kind of focus is outer
focus this is very important for example
in formulating strategy you need to
understand the ecosystem within which
your organization operates you need to
be able to sense what's going to work
what we'll need to do in the future and
so on and for that you need a kind of
systems view big-picture thinking the
sad story here is actually the
blackberry there are two kinds of
basically two kinds of strategic
thinking one is exploitation the other
is exploration in exploitation you take
a product or a brand that's worked very
very well and you fine-tune it you tweak
it you keep making it better because it
keeps working for you that's what
blackberry did the danger is if you
don't also explore exploration means you
see you look widely you see what's
happening where things are going you do
R&D you try to come up with the next new
thing and they failed they failed to see
for example Samsung they failed to see
what the competition was doing if you so
if you don't have an inner focus and an
other focus and an outer focus the
danger is being rudderless clueless or
blindsided attention is a mental muscle
it's it's like going to the gym if you
go to the gym and you lift weights every
time you do a repetition you strengthen
the muscle that you're working a tension
can be strengthened in the same way in
fact I think I'll show you how if you're
interested it just take two minutes all
you have to do is sit straight up
close your eyes and bring your attention
to your breath don't try to control your
breath just watch your breath to observe
it try to sense it coming in and out
maybe your nostrils and watch every
breath the full in-breath the full
out-breath start over again with the
next breath and just start again with
the next breath be fully aware of the
sensation and if you find that your mind
is somewhere else
bring it back again and gently restart
now you can open your eyes but did
anybody notice their mind wandering did
anybody bring it back
that's the rep actually the exercise is
not keeping your mind focus the exercise
is when it wanders bringing it back
that's what strengthens the connectivity
in the attentional circuitry this is a
study that was done at Emory University
and this is a basic muscle to mind
what's interesting to me is that we
don't exercise it typically we depend on
externals
to grab our attention in fact our
economy in a sense is built on the
grabbing of attention habituation is
what the brain does when it's this sees
the same old thing day after day after
day save walking the same way to work or
whatever it is you don't see it after a
while the brain economizes on attention
orienting on the other hand is opening
up it's whenever the brain encounter is
something new novel and surprising it
excites the brain and think about it
every season there's a new fashion well
what is a new fashion it's actually a
minor variation on a basic product every
year there's a new car well what's a new
car it's just enough difference to
excite the orienting response so it's
the basis of our economy it's a very
radical move to cultivate the ability to
manage your own mind so that you can
orient at will but that's exactly what's
possible with the tension training and I
become a big advocate of it one of the
reason is the research Richard Davidson
who's a neuroscientist at the University
of Wisconsin has expertise in the brain
and emotion and he's found in his
research that when were agitated when
we're upset and angry and anxious
there's a lot of activity in the right
prefrontal area just behind the floor
also in the amygdala of the brains
trigger point for the fight flight
freeze response when we're on the other
hand in a really positive state I feel
great enthusiastic what a wonderful day
there's a lot of activity on the left
side and no activity on the right each
of us has a renter ratio at rest of
right-to-left activity that predicts our
mood range day to day he finds there's a
bell curve for this like for IQ most of
us are in the middle we have bad days we
have good days if you're very far to the
right you may be clinically depressed a
clinically anxious if you're very far to
the left you're very resilient you
bounce right back from setbacks so
Davidson paired up with a fella named
Jon kabat-zinn who has made mindfulness
as he calls it very popular for example
in the in the medical sector as a way to
manage chronic conditions and also in
the states of leasing business recently
a lot of businesses are bringing it in
and it's more or less what we just did
Davidson and kabat-zinn went to a
biotech startup 24/7 you know high
pressure environment and they taught
people how to do mindfulness which is
more or less the exercise of watching
the breath but they did it 30 minutes a
day for eight weeks what he found was
that before that people's brains were
tilted to the right they're pretty
hassled and stressed after eight weeks
30 minutes a day they were tilting back
toward the left and what's very
interesting is people spontaneously
started saying hey you know I'm starting
to enjoy my work again
I remember what I loved about this job
in other words the positive mood was
really making a difference there's one
reason that businesses are bringing it
in I myself feel that it's not we adults
who
our most in need of paying attention to
attention in this way I think it's
children because childhood has changed
childhood has changed as a side effect
of this onslaught of the digital world
into our personal universe I was talking
to an 8th grade teacher who was
complaining about how kids now are
texting in the States I didn't know
about here texting has overcome phone
calls among teenagers as a preferred way
to connect their kids who will send a
hundred texts a day to their friends and
that's that's not unusual
she said you know for 20 years I've been
teaching the same book to my 13 year
olds it's Edith Hamilton's mythology and
she said in the last two three four
years my students are starting to say
they're having trouble reading this it's
a little too hard and she attributes it
to a loss of ability to comprehend
because of this constant distraction
I saw a kid maybe nine or ten years old
riding a bicycle and texting while he
was riding can you believe that luckily
it was in the country on a country lane
the reason I'm worried about children is
that the brain is the last organ of the
body to become anatomically mature it
starts growing from birth and it
actually doesn't finish until the mid
20s during that time the principle of
neuroplasticity is extremely important
neuroplasticity says that repeated
experiences shape the brain use it or
lose it as another way of saying it if a
child has an experience for example of
empathy and another experience of
empathy the circuitry for empathy grows
if a child has experience of paying full
attention and ignoring distractors which
is what we just did the connectivity for
that circuitry grows and children need
this in order for their brains to
develop well when we see a child grow
and go through different phases of
childhood what we're seeing are the
external signs of brain growth and I
think it's it's incumbent on us to help
children shape their brains in the best
way I was in classroom of seven year
olds in Spanish Harlem in Manhattan
Spanish Harlem is a very impoverished
place the children they're living in
housing projects and the projects are
pretty dire one child came to class the
teacher told me and was a little shaken
he just seen somebody shot and the
teacher said how many how many of you
have know someone who's been shot every
hand went up it's that kind of childhood
it's a very tough place and I happen to
be there to watch something called
breathing buddies every day this
classroom all the kids have a session
where they go to their little cubbies
and they get a favorite stuffed animal
and they lie it down on a rug on the
floor they put the animal on their belly
and they watch it go up with the in
breath and down when they breathe out
and they count one two three on them one
two three on the out-breath
and they're doing exactly what we just
did exactly what they're strengthening
the capacity the mental muscle of
attention there's something else there's
a twofer here because the same circuitry
also calms stormy emotions the ability
to manage emotions is inextricably
linked with the ability to pay attention
and the teacher said you know one day
because of a scheduling problem we had
to skip this and the class was chaotic
the class was chaotic so it makes a huge
difference for these kids I've long been
an advocate of what's called social
emotional learning social emotional
learning takes the emotional
intelligence component self-awareness
managing your inner life empathy
handling relationships and makes it part
of the curriculum not in a way that
takes away from academics but in a way
that enhances children's ability to
handle themselves and their
relationships and children's
relationships if your paradise
need to tell you this but from puberty
on before puberty the most important
relationships in a child's life are
family after puberty forget family it's
other kids and the melodramas of
childhood they didn't invite me to the
party whatever it me capture attention
those are emotional upsets the more you
can manage those upsets the more
attentional capacity you have to hear
what the teacher is saying one of the
things they do in these classes in these
programs I've seen this in New Haven in
a neighborhood very similar to Spanish
Harlem there's a a poster on the wall of
every classroom it's a stop like a
traffic light red light yellow light
green light
it says when you're upset remember the
stop light red light stop calm down and
think before you act
well stop says you have a choice
calm down means you can manage your
inner turmoil think before you act is a
very valuable lesson because it says you
can't determine what emotions you're
going to have our emotions come unbidden
but once you have them you can stop and
think what you're going to do in fact
one definition of maturity is
lengthening the gap between impulse and
action
yellow light think of a range of things
you could do and what the consequences
might be
green light pick the best one and try it
out this is a lesson in what's called
cognitive control some of you may know
about the marshmallow test it's another
legendary study in psychology
four-year-olds at Stanford University or
brought into a room one by one sat down
as a small table big juicy marshmallow
put in front of them the experimenter
says to this for you you can have the
marshmallow now if you want but if you
don't eat it till I come back from
running an errand you can have to then
then she leaves the room this is a
predicament that tries the soul of any
four-year-old
I assure you I've seen video on it some
of them will go up and sniff it is over
dangerous and then jump back and others
go off and sing and dance themselves in
a corner to stay distracted about a
third of the kids can't stand it they
just grab it and gobble it down on the
spot and another third or so wait the
endless 1012 minutes until the
experimenter comes back and they get the
two marshmallows the payoff from the
study came 14 years later when they're
tracked down as they're about to go to
university and the two groups are
compared the ones who gobbled the ones
who waited and it turns out the ones who
waited get along much better with their
peers they're still able to delay
gratification and pursuit of their goals
which is exactly what that's a test of
and this was a surprise on the american
university entrance exam the SAT which
at that time had 1600 total points the
kids who waited had a 210 point
advantage over the kids who grabbed this
is really interesting because these are
all children of parents at stanford
university these are high IQ high
achieving families so what's going on
but the difference seems to be that if
you're not able to manage your impulse
and mind-wandering is kind of a
microcosm of that then you're going to
be more upset you're going to be more
emotional you're not going to be able to
pay attention to what the teacher is
saying so you can't learn as well there
was a study done just a few years ago in
New Zealand every child in a city in New
Zealand became part who was born over
course of a year became part of the
study from ages four to eight they were
rigorously tested on cognitive control
many different measures including the
marshmallow type test and then when
they're in their 30s they tracked down
again and it turned out the cognitive
control the ability keep your mind here
or bring it back when it wanders was a
better predictor of financial success
and health in the mid-30s than either IQ
or the social economic status of the
family
and it's a completely independent factor
in fact the people who did the study
argue that we should be teaching this
ability to children in order to level
the playing field so this is becoming
part of social-emotional learning social
emotional learning though also means
being smart about your relationships so
here's something that happened in New
Haven among eleven-year-old boys they're
going to play what we call soccer I
think you erroneously call it football
here is that right so the these kids
were three boys going to play slightly
the first kid is kind of pudgy not very
athletic and the two kids behind them
very good at soccer very athletic and
they're making sarcastic remarks to this
first kid and one of the other kids says
to this first kid the big sneer oh so
you think you're going to play soccer
and the pudgy kid stops takes a deep
breath as though to brace himself for
the confrontation I had this could
easily lead to a fight in the school
turns around and says yeah I'm gonna try
to play soccer I'm not very good at it
what I'm good at his art show me
anything I can draw her really well but
you you're fantastic at soccer someday
I'd like to be as good as you are and at
that the other kid just melts comes up
puts his arm around and says oh you're
not so bad let me show you a thing or
two that was no accident that is called
a put-up that Boyd learned it in his sel
it's a way to handle put-downs which is
a very big problem in the teenage early
teen years and it's just part of a wider
curriculum which pays attention to what
matters to kids and attention needs to
be part of that curriculum and it's not
just schools you know parents of the
first coach and all of this when you
pick up a baby who's crying and soothe
her you're actually teaching her how to
soothe herself when you point out to a
toddler you know when you did that it
made your friend feel bad that's a
lesson in
empathy so it's you know these the
lessons in attention and emotional
intelligence start very very early in
life but I think we've got to get better
at it one reason is the kids are being
exposed more and more to influences that
aren't so great I don't know if you know
anyone any youngster who likes video
games and spends hours that then maybe
it doesn't happen here in London but
it's a big problem worldwide and the
data on video games is rather mixed for
one thing they actually do enhance some
aspects of attention if you're a kid who
likes to play fighting games you know
battle games and you have to be
constantly on the lookout for the enemy
who might pop up and kill you it's very
good for enhancing vigilance you could
be a very good air traffic controller
for example however it also means that
if a kid happens to bump you in the
hallway your first thought is that he
has a grudge against you you get a bias
toward hostile attribution so the video
games that we have now are rather mixed
but there's a new generation coming
along which is using findings from
cognitive science there's one called
tenacity that I had my four
grandchildren play ages 7 to 13 at the
time in tenacity you have an iPad every
time you breathe out you tap the screen
on the fifth out-breath you tap it twice
if you do that you get a visual reward
you know flowers blooming in the desert
as you do it more and more it gets
harder and harder so basically what it's
doing is training attention but in a way
that keeps the attention of kids the
same way that all the other video games
do there are there are other things that
we could be using you know the media
generally and I say this is a reformed
journalist the media gives us a very
toxic view of the world most of the news
we get is about disaster
death threats horrible things happening
to people it's news for the amygdala the
amend oh is a very primitive part of the
brain that wants to know what are the
dangers however if we were to take on
any given day all of the acts of
kindness performed around the globe you
know a mom
feeding her kid is an act of kindness
and we would put it on one scale and
then were to take all the atrocious acts
and put them on the loser scale the acts
of kindness would far outweigh those of
meanness but we don't get that sense of
the world looking through a media lens
but you we can use the media better one
example I like is Sesame Street if you
have ever if you have a toddler I've had
a toddler you may have watched Sesame
Street Sesame Street I found when I
visited Sesame Workshop is actually a
very sophisticated operation the day I
went there the script writers were
meeting with two cognitive scientists
they're actually meeting about cognitive
control because Sesame Street segments
turn out to be lessons based in science
wrapped in entertainment one of the
things that segments that aired this
season is the cookie connoisseur Club I
know if you're familiar with Cookie
Monster Cookie Monster is one of the
stars of Sesame Street and he loves to
gobble cookies but Alan who runs a store
on Sesame Street decided to start a
cookie connoisseur Club very much like a
wine connoisseur club and the cookie
connoisseur Club you take a cookie and
you study it to see if they're
imperfections then you sniff it for
aroma and then you take a nibble to
taste it
Cookie Monster of course was dying to
get into the club so Alan gives him a
cookie and he instantly gobbles it down
he can't restrain himself so Alan tells
him you know in this club we're going to
try all kinds of cookies so if you don't
gobble it down I can
you into the club and you're going to be
able to eat many many different kinds of
cookie that does it for cookie so that's
a lesson this is a show that is loved by
two to four year olds and two to four
year olds learn largely by modeling so
what's happening with cookie is that
people that the kids are learning a
lesson in cognitive control and I think
the more of that the better so let me
finish with by telling you about a smart
use of positive emotion of being able to
manage our own internal world of that
inner focus there is a remarkable man
named matthieu ricard he's written some
books on happiness he's his friend she
has a doctorate in cell biology from
Pasteur Institute his mentor there
actually won a Nobel Prize for the
research they're doing but after
graduate school he made a startling
decision he decided he'd give up science
and go to the Himalayas become a monk
and meditate for the rest of his life
he's been called I think by his
publishers publicists the happiest man
in the world because he's been studied
by scientists and on this right-to-left
ratio he's very far to the left there's
a scientist named Paul Ekman who's the
world's expert on the facial expression
of emotion Paul is the keenest observer
of the face as a revealer of what you're
feeling is a very dangerous man I once
was walking down the street with Paul on
the way to a meeting that I was
conducting and Paul was telling me about
a system for training people to get good
at this that he had just developed and
as he's telling it we're getting to the
meeting hall and I thought this is
really interesting but I hope he wraps
it up I've got to think about what I'm
gonna do in the meeting at that moment
he says to me and if someone had studied
the system they'd know you're getting a
little angry with me right now this is
why pathes so dangerous
Paul was interested in emotional
contagion he wanted to know what would
the effect be
someone like Mathieu who was very very
upbeat on someone who was quite the
opposite
so Paul did a quiet phone survey of
faculty at the University of where he
teaches asking who is the most abrasive
difficult confrontational member of our
faculty oddly enough
everyone agreed who that was so he calls
Professor X aces in the interests of
science would you take part in a
scientific experiment and the
professor's delighted said sure I'd be
happy to as the day drew near and error
he started making demands which became
increasingly outrageous and so they had
to dump him and go with the second most
difficult professor and the experiment
was they're both they're having the
Mathieu and the professor have their
physiology measured and they're going to
have a debate the debate is on the
premise that the professor should do
with Mathieu did the professor had a
very influential secure well-paid
tenured position but the premise of the
debate was that he would give it up and
become a monk and go to Hermitage for
the rest of his life at the beginning of
this debate that physiology showed he
was really agitated at the thought of
that Mathieu was totally calm
so as the discussion starts Mathieu
stays absolutely calm and the professor
gets calmer and calmer and calmer by the
end of 15 minutes he's having such a
good time he doesn't want to stop the
discussion so our emotions are
contagious for better or for worse
particularly when we pay full attention
to each other I once was waiting for a
bus on a very hot humid day in New York
City in August it's the kind of day I
don't know about London but in New York
we have a rather invisible balloon
around us we're feeling a little prickly
it says don't talk to me don't touch me
and my balloon intact and the bus pulls
up get on with my balloon and the bus
driver did something quite surprising he
actually spoke to me he said how is
they Bend I was shocked but I sat down
taking most of my bubble with me then I
realized this bus drivers carrying on a
conversation with everyone on the bus
you're looking for suits I you know
there's a great sale over here on the
right in this department store and did
you hear about the Monnet exhibit on the
Left that the means wonderful and the
Cineplex on were coming to here I know
the movie and cinema for got the best
reviews but the one in cinema 2 shot the
other night fantastic you should on and
on like that and then people would get
off the bus and he'd say to them I hope
the rest of your day is really wonderful
that man was an urban Saint he
transformed everyone on the bus he was
sending ripples of good feeling through
a city that sorely needed it and I think
the bottom line is you know you don't
have to go to the Himalayas for decades
we all can do that in our lives if we
pay attention thank you very much
so I'm happy to I'm happy to answer any
questions you might have their mics here
and there's standing might some tools in
the galleries so just raise your hand if
you have a question first question over
here
you mentioned the low cultures in
America where there are murders every
day Steven Pinker writes very well about
some of these cultures and explains that
people will be killed over a simple
slight a disrespect or something and
it's ingrained in the culture it's
innate the thing that I can see there's
a there seems to be an insidious
political correctness in the world today
where we're not allowed to say that a
culture is a rubbish culture and in
doing that we don't address the problems
with these people so every day they
continue to have the low expectations
the murders the the social Melia that
creates and continues to create what you
in America called the broken window
syndrome and I wondered what your view
was on the inability for people to
address these problems honestly and
openly and even going on to the fact
that a lot of our condition is
genetically inherited the brain is no
different to any other organ in the body
that whole groups of people get a
particular kind of genetics sure well I
think there's a very young after that
it's it's not being addressed at all and
we're losing out over that yes well I
know of some data which speaks directly
to that I think first of all we have to
be very careful about stereotypes
because in any given neighborhood
there's a range of variation who happens
to live there there may happen to be
some very talented young people who live
in a neighborhood which is otherwise
rife with problems so for one thing we
should allow for individual differences
but generally it's a worldwide problem
what to do with children who grow up in
dire poverty because from one thing the
brain is very fragile so if you're not
well nourished in childhood the brain
doesn't grow as well
and worldwide children who grew up in
poverty can have undernourished brains
which makes them susceptible to all
kinds of behavioral problems
particularly when it comes to prefrontal
development as I mentioned that the
prefrontal area is the one that manages
emotions so if you can't handle your
rage for instance many people who end up
in murderers row who have killed someone
have a damage to the prefrontal areas
it's been found so we need to face this
as you suggest starkly and see what the
problems are and what the possible
interventions might be because I would
never write off an entire group of
children I would say instead these are
developing brains let's help them
develop as well as they could and in
fact I mentioned that the New Zealand
study suggested that we have active
interventions particularly an early
childhood there's a famous study done in
the it's called the Perry PE rry
preschool study where children hadn't
written children from a neighborhood
like this at a very enriched program and
they did much much better in life than
other kids from the same neighborhood
and the question of IQ and class is very
important to understand in cultures
worldwide where there's a privileged
caste or class and an underprivileged
caste or class there was always a wide
gap in IQ scores between the privileged
and the underprivileged and it's taken
to be genetic however there's something
called the Flynn effect Flynn is a
researcher at the University of Otago in
New Zealand and he's shown with vast
datasets that every three four five
years when IQ tests are revised they
have to make questions harder they have
to make questions harder because kids
become smarter every generation than
previous generations in other words it's
not fixed the other thing he's found is
that when children a group from a caste
which is our class which is
underprivileged migrates to a country
were the bias about that caste
class doesn't exist their children do as
well as other children so it's not
genetic it's largely situational so
you're absolutely right we have to look
squarely at those situations and see
what we can do to help where is the mic
next question hello there thank you for
your talk very much enjoyed it
my question relates back to the the
situation of the marshmallows and you
said if you give one child one yes
before you all to have one one and if
one eats one later then he'll have two
and you said when they got to their 30s
you know the high achievers were the
ones who waited right how much of that
is linked to addiction you mean wanting
the two marshmallows right away you
could get addicted to marshmallows I
think no but is that youth yes yeah
exactly the inability to control impulse
makes one susceptible to alcoholism
addiction Shopaholic gambling addiction
and so on because you you want the hit
and you you don't restrain yourself and
see that there are other ways to go yeah
by the way don't try that at home with
your child the marshmallow test I know
someone who tried it with his
four-year-old daughter and he peeked to
see what she did he put the marshmallow
and left the room she took the
marshmallow she took out the middle of
the marshmallow and ate it and then put
it back
she's probably CEO of a company now I
died
I have good news good news and bad news
if the brain becomes anatomically mature
in the mid-20s but doesn't mean it's too
late to change habit
however habits instantiated in the brain
in childhood are very strong so if you
end up say addicted or overly anxious or
whatever it may be it's still possible
to change but you need to make an added
effort and the reason is that you have
to practice the new healthy better
behavior over and over because you've
practiced the bad way 10,000 times you
know you've done it over and over in the
circuitry is so strong but here cross
your arms this is what a habit feels
like now cross them the other way with
the other arm on top
that's what it feels like to change a
habit it's a little weird at first
little that's strange but if you make
the effort and keep making the effort at
every naturally occurring opportunity
what happens is the neural connectivity
for the new pathway gets stronger and
stronger until at some point you pass a
developmental landmark a neural landmark
where you do the new habit you perform
the new habit effortlessly without
thinking about it becomes automatic and
what that means is that the connectivity
for the new habit has now become
stronger than the old one it's the
brains now the brains default choice but
takes work takes more work my question
is about the three focuses that you
mentioned the inner the other and the
answer I won I'm wondering whether they
exist in isolation or whether they exist
in a hierarchy and if so is there a
method of moving through them well I
think they each can be improved I don't
think there's a hierarchy because for
example in research on leaders we found
that some leaders can be very good at
any two or one of them and bad
any of the others right in other words
every combination is possible you can be
really emotionally intelligent manage
yourself well manage other people well
but be absolutely blind to systems and
to the larger context in which your
organization is operating or you can be
very good at managing yourself and very
bad at reading people there are actually
a lot of in the workplace there is a
whole class of people who are
outstanding individual contributors
often very good at systems and work very
hard computer programmers for example
who have zero empathy I was talking to
someone here in Europe who was with the
company and he said we have a guy who is
absolutely brilliant at systems and we
can't put him in front of a client
because when we do he just starts
talking non-stop
he never stops to you know meet the
client to find out what's on their mind
to understand the problem from their
point of view so here's someone who's
very good at inner and managing himself
and its systems but not people
is you mean is attention handled
differently within different or value
differently absolutely sure oh yeah I
mean culture that the culture makes an
enormous difference particularly for
example in valuing attention attention
training most of the attention training
methods we use now come from Eastern
cultures because because Eastern
cultures like Bhutan for example many
people in Bhutan and meditators may be
to some extent almost all of them all of
the citizens it's part of the culture
it's part of the background and so the
methodologies they have were quite
sophisticated they've been developed
over millennia and people like Richard
Davidson who I mentioned who do research
in this area are using expert advisors
from those cultures to help him
understand what is what the potential is
for us to train attention because in the
West we're rather stunted in our view of
how to train attention so I think when
it comes to to a mental faculty culture
makes an enormous difference the same
thing just true by the way of emotions
every every culture values and expresses
emotions differently everyone
universally has the same wiring for
emotion our our emotions are contagious
yes therefore should we spend more or
less time with our angry colleagues
should we be the American bus driver or
the French monk should we save the world
or save ourselves
hahahahaha well the French monk is
actually good at saving everyone that's
his mission but apart from that I think
that it's important to understand the
dynamic of sending and receiving
emotions so there are several factors
that determine in any given interaction
who sins and who receives there are
studies done for example where two
strangers come into a lab they fill out
a questionnaire mood questionnaire or
how do you feel right now
then they sit facing each other in
silence for two minutes then they fill
out the same
genera turns out the person in that diet
who's most emotionally expressive
transmits his or her emotional state to
the other person in two silent minutes
so expressivity is very important on the
other hand power matters in any human
group it's natural to pay most attention
to and put most importance on but the
most powerful person in that group says
and does so emotions tend to spread from
the person who has power outward what
this means for example these are
experiments done on Keynes if the leader
of a team is in a very bad mood people
on the team catch the mood and
performance goes down if the leader of
the team is in a very good mood a
positive mood people catch that and
performance goes up and this is true for
business decisions for creativity for
physical coordination like putting up a
tent so that's a second factor is the
power relationship the third factor has
to do with Mathieu Picard and that is
how stable are you if you are going to
go and be with your angry colleague are
you stable enough in a positive state
that like him you can bring or the bus
driver you can bring him into that state
are you gonna end up angry yourself so
those are at least three factors that
might determine the answer fascinated by
the advocacy of social emotional
learning yes and it would appear that
there are many Western parents today who
have glommed onto the same focus in
prescribing ritalin for many of their
kids can you take a minute and talk a
little bit about you've described an
organic approach to improving focus and
I look forward to reading more about
those but what are the impact of the
over prescription of Ritalin
what are the effect in this long-term
effects right so ritalin which of course
is given to children who have so-called
ADHD attentional deficit hyperactivity
disorder you know 50 years ago they used
to say well he's just a little boy he'll
outgrow it but now it's a become a
diagnostic category and there's some
kids who have genuine
problems paying attention they're not
being helped by digital media as they
are today they would be very helped by
these lessons in cognitive control which
are very new and are just now being
studied so they're people like Davidson
are studying the ways in which we can
use attentional training think about it
why has this culture had as its default
buying a drug and giving it to our
children for something which is a skill
deficit it's a skill deficit tension is
a skill I think the reason is there are
drug companies who are making a lot of
money selling us those drugs and
convincing us that this is the better
alternative this is my personal opinion
when in fact what we have not done is
basic research on the attentional
mechanisms involved in ADHD and what
kind of training would help children get
better at it and I think within the next
five years we're going to see a set of
very direct interventions that are
non-pharmaceutical in those conditions I
just wanted to ask your opinion is to
what extent do you think our emotional
reactions are learned or innate well our
emotions are innate I think and our
particular emotional reactions are
largely learned I have to recommend my
wife's book here it's called mind
whispering her name's Tara Bennett gomen
she's a psychotherapist because she
talks about the way in which emotional
patterns of reactivity are learned in
childhood and how you could use
mindfulness cognitive therapy a number
of interventions to change the habits
that are self-defeating the name of the
book is mind whispering and her name is
Tara Bennett goleman I found it very
useful actually find her even more
useful
actually there's data on that if you're
a pessimist can you learn to be an
optimist and there's research done by a
fella named Martin Seligman at
University of Pennsylvania who developed
a field called positive psychology he
developed the field because psychology
for 80 years only studied pathology so
there was a problem we hadn't noticed
that there was a positive spectrum of
emotion and experience but any rate
Seligman took kids who were prone to
depression
turned out that they tended to be
pessimists and to see if they had
something that didn't work out or a
setback in life they'd say it's because
of me and I'll always be like that and
he taught them to think differently well
it was the circumstance circumstances
can change and I can do something to
change them it's a more optimistic
outlook and he found that actually after
about a year their thinking patterns had
changed but it's what I said
as with any such behavior we have to
keep at it and keep at it at every
naturally occurring opportunity and
catch ourselves when we go back to the
you know the old pattern so yes optimism
can be learned
I actually know the the gentleman who
invented cognitive therapy cognitive
therapy looks at our thinking distorted
thinking patterns and helps us see more
realistically and it's very effective
for depression his name is Aaron Beck
he's 93 now he had a terrible accident
that put him in a wheelchair and
happened to speak to him after that and
he was very upbeat he's supposed one of
the most optimistic people I know then
he lost sight in one eye and I was
talking to me said well you know my
right eye works perfectly fine I can
still run and then he went blind in his
right eye and I said you know I can
still listen to books on tape in other
words he had the capacity to see what
was right instead of what's wrong which
is what you're talking about yes hi I
just had a question about the
performance graph that you have there
yeah you mentioned two extremes you have
the
motivated performance and and then you
have the frazzle and yes what can you do
if you're one of those types of people
what can I do how can you improve it
well we can do with this type of person
and with this type of person yeah well
let me ask you in this hypothetical
question are we this type of person are
we managing this type of person or a
friend of this who are we are we the
person a friend of this type of person
today talking I have a friend here that
all the days so what the person needs
who is under aroused who's disengaged is
involvement to get more motivated more
passionate more engaged and there's
something there's a literature now on
something called good work good work
combines three things it combines what
we're really good at our excellence with
what we're really passionate about what
engages us and what we value with our
ethics if you align those three things
you're naturally going to go up from
here to there in fact you'll you'll get
into flow much more easily so one
question to ask our friend is what would
be good work for you and what could you
do to make it a larger proportion of the
time in your day or your week or your
month or over the course of the next
five years of your career so that's a
kind of individual strategy for that if
you're here if you're frazzle in frazzle
what you need is calm so which is very
related to cognitive control but there
are many ways to calm down however if
you can't well there are there two
strategies if you're say frazzle because
you have a boss that asks you to do too
much in too little time and give too
little support you might get your boss's
CV and send it out to a headhunter but
that's
not an immediate solution so instead you
might manage your own world better by
finding something that works for you
that gets you physiologically relaxed it
might be meditation it might be yoga
might be deep muscle it might be working
out at the gym everyone is different do
it every day
and do it before you go to work or
whatever is frazzling you because what
happens is that over time your body set
point for stress changes and you'll be
able to manage better or to be in a more
relaxed state in in the circumstance two
general strategies yes I've got two
quick questions the first one might be a
silly question so I apologize if I've
missed this but do you see focus as an
extension of emotional intelligence or
is it cognitive or is it is it both
right so what I think is that attention
was embedded within emotional
intelligence because the brains circuits
for emotions for empathy and for
attention intermingle I just never
thought about it I didn't realize I had
to write a whole new book about it and
tonight okay the second question is I've
got a two-year-old son oh when he's four
I fully intend to do the marshmallow
just wandering between now and then are
there things that I could be doing for
him that will help him more be more
likely to wait you're probably doing
them already just being a good enough
parent is terrific yeah but pay
attention to you know your your child's
feelings needs that's very important I
wasn't entirely surprised to hear this
from my friend a little while ago who
works in a psychiatric resident hospital
and the difference between the emotions
of the sexes is absolutely enormous if a
woman comes in for a session the
psychotherapist will say how's it going
how are you
and I will come exactly how it's going
how they feel when a man comes in very
little is said so the psychotherapist
will say on the sofa over there are a
collection of soft toys pick why not
hahahahaha so the man will go and pick
up the Panda uh-huh and the
psychotherapist will say well how is mr.
panda today and then it will come the
difference of emotions between the sexes
however we like to think we are
basically all the same I think we are
hugely different so do I thank you well
I just wanted to make a response to the
gentleman with the two-year-old I have
three children and I'm sure that if all
three coming out of exactly the same
environment probably would react very
differently to the marshmallow test so
that goes back to my question is it
learned or innate and I think often that
some people just have a natural
emotional intelligence yes I didn't
answer question the answer is it's both
learned and innate in that each of us is
born with a particular range of set
points in the brain chemicals that
manage emotion that's our temperament
and as you know if you have more than
one child kids differ from day one on
the other hand epigenetics tells us that
it's not the genes you have it's which
genes turn on and off that will make the
lasting difference and the behavior in a
child is very malleable so if a child is
very impulsive that child can learn
cognitive control
if a child is too constricted that child
could learn to loosen up there's data on
children for example who are what are
called behaviorally inhibited this is
work of Jerome Kagan at Harvard he finds
that about 15% of children are anxious
of
new stimuli new playground new friend
new food and when they're very young
these are the kids who at school-age are
identified as shy and it had been
thought that this was just genetic but
what they he realized wouldn't he
followed a group of these kids was that
some of them by school-age weren't shy
and he looked at the parenting may God
and he noted he found that the
difference was this if your parents
identify you as she's shy and protect
you those are the children who don't
change if parents say to a child well
you may feel a little timid about it but
go ahead and try it anyway that child
learns I'll feel little scared at first
but if I go ahead I'm gonna have a good
time and those are the children who
don't end up shy so it's it's a
malleable mix of both yeah and I think
we've reached the end of our time Daniel
I think you've them held our attention
brilliantly peace will you join me in
thanking him for a really fascinating
stimulating
[Applause]